a histogram is just a special kind
of column graph
in fact that's basically what histogram
means i went and dug it up
uh it has to do with this part here this
history this
prefix has to do with anything that's
upright like for example the masts and
sales of a ship
right so it's a column graph as you can
see
but it has a couple of minor differences
so underneath here
number one you'll notice i sort of
pointed this out to you when we're doing
congrats before
do you see there are no no gaps between
the different columns do you see that
so it's got no gaps between columns
so that's a little minor difference and
secondly
you will see there's a graph a gap keep
saying graph there's a gap at the
beginning right
so there is a gap with the axis the
vertical one
okay so apart from that it's just a
regular
column graph as you're seeing now when
you get your data
what you're putting up onto the vertical
scale is pretty much always frequency so
in fact sometimes you'll
see this called frequency histograms
this is you remember how we said
sometimes you choose this
vertical that for horizontal you'll
always see frequency over here
okay now if i take the midpoint
of all of these columns okay so you
might want to
get another color in here so if you join
the midpoints
and you also take that line which joins
the midpoints and you connect it down to
the horizontal axis okay so join the
midpoints and the horizontal axis
what you've made as is labeled up on the
screen is a frequency
polygon because you have a shape that
connects everything
so this is like a fancy minecraft okay
this is the one time some people ask me
this
last lesson this is the one time where
your data here
it it starts here but actually you're
going to join it down at the bottom so
it's a
polygon okay so if you join the
midpoints and the horizontal axis
um that's what you do to create a
frequency folder
okay ash question do you have to do it
in the middle of
the access yeah i'm so glad you're
asking so
when we just have a normal over here
normal frequency
okay then yes it's the midpoint as
demonstrated
but there is a case when we don't do the
midpoints
but we do the corners so i'm going to
show that to you in just a second
just want you to get this is a frequency
histogram and therefore this
is a frequency polygon question um
well what's the use of having a wine
graph what did we use those for before
what were they used for yeah good if
there's a trend or like a pattern from
like all the different temperatures how
frequently i get them that's all it's
about
can you not tell them i think you're
just trying to make it more obvious
and sometimes maybe what you want is
just the frequency polygon
and you might not draw the original
histogram
in at all like just it might be too much
information for you so you just want to
make it a little cleaner okay
all right did anyone else have any
questions on the
frequency histogram frequency poles hold
on does that make sense yeah
okay so now um this is what um
who asked who asked about ash when we
were talking about well where are we
joining
i want to show you this so this is ever
so slightly different
ever so slightly different this is not a
frequency histogram it's not a frequency
polygon
have a look at the vertical axis
it's not frequency it's a cumulative
frequency which is why this thing is
climbing
okay so now underneath here this is just
a regular frequency histogram and
polygon
i've run out of space here but if you
can make a little subheading for me
which is not frequency but cumulative
frequency
history histograms and polygons
you've got some minor differences here
right so
let's look at what's common first um
you've still got
columns which don't have gaps you still
have a gap with the vertical axis
but what's different um have a look at
my polygon and see where it joins okay
i'm not at the midpoints anymore not
here here here
here and so on and at the corners um the
way i describe it is i'm joining the top
right corner of every column does that
make sense
so i've still got these features
here but to make a cumulative frequency
polygon
to create a cumulative
frequency polygon
instead of joining the midpoints i'm
going to join the top right corners of
each card
one last thing on this guy because you
can see it's going to end up all the way
up at the top
okay this is meant to be a thing that's
climbing um presumably if i had higher
temperatures on here 24 25 36
etc um this would keep on going up and
up and up
so for that reason rather than this one
which comes back down to the bottom okay
because look this is the shape of
things right um in the cumulative
frequency polygon
if this diagram continued it wouldn't go
down it's meant to accumulate it's meant
to get bigger
right so that's why you can see it ends
up there and it doesn't return
okay so you can say don't rejoin
the horizontal axis
now this graph comes up so much so many
people use it
that it gets its own special name and
maybe you've heard the special name
before does anyone know what it's called
starts with
but i mean you can say oh give us your
life because that's or
yeah i've never heard anyone say oh
drive because someone told me in roll
call this morning that it was ogives
yeah to be honest i have no idea how you
pronounce it
so long as you spell it right and you
know what it's talking about because you
pretty much won't have to say it except
to your friends
um again i'm going to pronounce it all
it is is another name for a cumulative
frequency
polygon that guy the green one okay
right now one more point before i um
read this notice to you remember i
started by saying histograms they're
kind of just like a special
holograph why do we have these they're
not that different
okay i will show you why um in the rest
of the world
this is what people think of when they
think of a histogram
okay now i want you to look at it
what strikes you as strange about this
chart this graph
there are chunks there are chunks um i
need to think about the chunks i mean
just
coming back this has chunks too right
like they're chunks
yeah okay so there's a couple of things
happening going on at the same time
um they're uneven and the reason they're
uneven is because
these things down here thinking back to
like last week a few lessons ago
these are not individual scores they're
yeah it's a range
these are classes or intervals you might
remember those words from before we
looked at group data
okay now what's going on here the idea
is that okay
people aged one to six how many are
there people age six to eight
people aged eight to eleven you have
different ranges
the width of a column means there are
more people there okay
so to compensate this guy over here
is actually not um a time there's not
eight people who are aged
one to six because it's wider
this is going to go up this is actually
one two three four five
squares you can actually just see them
right so there's actually five times
eight there are 40 people
in this class right a bigger rectangle
means more people
this is trying to get away from the
misleading graphs we're looking at
before where people use area and it's a
bit sneaky or volume
have a look how many people are aged six
to eight
how would you read it there are going to
be it's 20
high but it's too wide so it'd be 40 and
you could go by the same principle and
say um this goes up to 13.
and that's three white so that would be
39 people do okay
now if that feels weird and confusing to
you
then you're not alone the people who've
designed the new south wales massive
have said
that's crazy and confusing don't care if
the rest of the world does that
we're not going to deal with histograms
that have this weird funky thing down
here
good so that's why that's why for us for
our intents and purposes
they're basically just column graphs
without gaps okay that's basically what
it means
okay however if you go out in the real
world or you go to another country right
and they're like hey yeah
this thing right it's a histogram but
the width is meaningful as opposed to
for us
the width could be anything you want
okay